jean marc sylvestre bonjour alors tout
d'abord est ce qu'on peut imaginer le
contenu de ces trois grands chantiers
selon on a très peu d'informations pour
l'instant ce que l'on sait c'est que
emmanuel macron ne veut pas
fondamentalement changé de cap il veut
changer la façon de faire
la manière de faire mais sur le cap il
est toujours sur celui qui l'avait déjà
initiés on a peu d'informations on
connaît les besoins en connaît les
besoins immédiats
il faut régler le problème des retraites
jean castex l'a déjà dit il faut aussi
finaliser les négociations sur le ségur
de la santé notamment les soignants qui
sont en attente du montant de la
revalorisation de leurs salaires mais
pour la rentrée
eh bien il va falloir s'atteler à trois
grands chantiers vous en parliez 1 c'est
la relance c'est le premier chantier la
relance de l'économie il faut faire
repartir des entreprises le miz
l'économie a déjà fait avancer les
choses il faut retrouver de la
croissance
ça passe essentiellement par
l'investissement et cet investissement
il ne peut être financée que par des
baisses d'impôts
c'est un peu le leitmotiv dont on
entendra parler baisses d'impôts
notamment des baisses d'impôts de
production qui met la france en
concurrence défavorable par rapport à
ses voisins européens c'est un pot de
production vous avez on les voit pas
beaucoup mais représentent trois et demi
pour cent de la valeur ajoutée ça passe
aussi
alors ça c'est un peu un sujet bateau en
france par des simplifications
administratives ou par un allègement des
normes et des procédures le deuxième
chantier eh bien il va constituer à
réduire au maximum les plans sociaux qui
ont déjà été annoncés air france airbus
mais y en a beaucoup d'autres
parce qu'on risque d'avoir une vague
déferlante de chômage à la rentrée
alors là on n'a pas de remède miracle il
va falloir faire du traitement social
c'est-à-dire du 2-2 du chômage partiel
du chômage des départs volontaires
et puis le troisième chantier alors là
il est beaucoup plus floue il est
beaucoup plus flou parce qu'il s'agit de
lancer des projets sur le climat sur
l'environnement bien déjà eu pas mal de
chose de prévu puisqu'on a eu le la
convention du climat la convention
citoyenne
mais il faut maintenant mettre de
l'ordre dans tout ça et puis surtout
mettre en oeuvre ces chantiers sont il
réalisable financièrement jean-marc
financièrement
grosso modo c'est une cité réalisable
l'activité économique retrouve de la
croissance parce que la croissance est
la mère de toutes les possibilités
on a des recettes fiscales on aura des
recettes sociales
donc on peut le faire mais il va falloir
aussi deux choses la première c'est
qu'il faut continuer d'emprunter de
l'argent à bakou par la bce la banque
centrale européenne on va avoir besoin
de la banque centrale européenne
et puis on pas aussi à part besoin dé
solidarité européenne qui sont promises
par la nouvelle présidente de l'union
européenne angela merkel au terme d'un
accord d'ailleurs qui avait été passé
par emmanuel macron mais il faut encore
mettre d'accord tous les autres pays
membres de l'union européenne c'est ce
qui sera fait d'ailleurs pour faire du
moins on l'espère lors d'un sommet la
semaine prochaine et politiquement est
ce réalisable selon vous la
politiquement là vous touchez le dossier
le pub le plus compliqué parce que la
mise en place de ces chantiers de
réforme va mettre en évidence des
contradictions qui existent entre les
contraintes de la relance économique
social ces objectifs là et lui les
objectifs de lutte pour l'environnement
vous savez d'un côté il faut faire la
croissance d'un côté il faut faire de la
consommation de l'exportation de la
production il faut créer des emplois et
puis de l'autre et bien vous avez des
écologistes qui plaident plutôt pour un
système un peu différent avec des
régulations peut-être avec des
interdictions pour moins produire pour
moins consommer moins voyager bref pour
faire moins de croissance il ya toujours
eu des contradictions entre l'économie
la production la croissance
et puis l'écologie mais elles deviennent
très fort il faut créer des emplois d'un
côté ils font augmenter par exemple les
personnels soignants il faut investir
pour trouver des vaccins des traitements
mais de l'autre et bien les écologistes
plaident plutôt pour une prudence dans
tous ces domaines croissance écologie
font pas bon ménage
vous savez la révolte et gilet jaune
n'est pas une révolte pour l'écologie
c'était une révolte pour des facilités
de mobilité une essence moins chère des
autoroutes plus le plus clair et c est
bien
les ministres de l'écologie ce sont de
tout temps retrouvé devant le mur des
réalités le mur une réalité par exemple
sauter la taxe carbone alors obligés
d'abandonner leurs promesses
irréalisables et bien la plupart des
écologistes avaient un certain nombre de
problèmes c'est la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui le goût
le mans a beaucoup de mal à se
constituer au niveau justement de ce
pôle écologique et à l'heure qu'il est
on ne connaît pas le probable futur
ministre de l'écologie je ne crois pas
qu'il y en ait un de possibles dans la
nouvelle équipe gouvernementale
ou alors on va avoir des difficultés
souvenez-vous s'il s'était passé avec
nicolas hulot ya pas beaucoup de
candidats jean marc sylvestre
journaliste éditorialiste économique
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions